fresh off of a Thursday night football
game for the ages but let's talk about
Murder on the Orient Express which in
theaters near you
number 10 such cruelty sorry Josh
alright let's get right let's just talk
about the elephant in the room yeah
right off the bat with Josh GAD here on
the Rich Eisen show dot our dolphin fan
from way back in the day car died being
the operative word
what what there's something in the water
I can't figure out what's going on
whether it's coaches doing cocaine on
tape or that was the thing that happened
a bully gate like every year it's
something and I and I love it because
it's entertaining but at the same time I
just would love just just a playoff run
that's all as a dolphin fan
I want Matt Moore is a great guy I think
he's I think he's tremendous I think he
caved under the pressure last night
there's no other way to put it they
really I mean I honestly thought that he
was gonna come in and then show how well
run a gays offense yeah he had a great
run last season if you went out like
something's not clicking right now
here's I don't want to play devil's
advocate because there are no excuses in
the NFL but there was a hurricane that
started off the season that hit South
Florida yeah we were we were out not
only our starting quarterback but we
were out some key players offensive and
defensive you then have one bye week at
the start of the season and ever since
we're literally going nonstop that's a
lot for a team to handle and I can
appreciate how tired they must be but
other than that it's we're running out
of excuses it's it's rough right now
even with that rough start they were
foreign to going into last night's game
yeah and I again I was just stunned at
how you know and you have to I guess tip
your cap to the Ravens defense which
dismantled its previous opponent as well
yeah you know so you have to tip your
cap to them I don't have to do anything
I don't want to
here's how this is like this was my
night so I kept my daughter's up to
watch the game with me because I was so
excited all today three and six and I
like let them watch a little bit and as
the bloodbath just got worse and worse
I'm like it's time for bad girls but
they're late but daddy you said that we
could I might go to bed now you can't
see any more of this this is a horror
film now see abend I went through two
Saturdays ago Michigan Oh being
destroyed by Penn State yeah and the
Yankees losing in a game seven of the
ALCS the same both ruff and I thought
this would be a teachable moment for my
children you see what it's like because
you lose games sometimes in life things
don't go your way
yeah but think of the Girardi thing as
the Yankees I was still sure you [ __ ]
I was surprised about it I was really
shocked you know but I was wondering
maybe that means we could get Mattingly
to come back and you're right he will
come back to the Marlins because
remember by the way coach does first
season he was addy was a manager of the
year his manager of the year and I could
never understand why Jeffrey Lurie I got
rid of him doesn't it sound like a
creepy reality TV show manager swamp
yeah would that be yeah real managers of
the major league it actually is could be
really it I feel like I feel like you
and I should probably go pictures
probably workshop I think we are I
believe that's what this is and I'm
all-in
it's Josh GAD Murder on the Orient
Express in theaters near you next month
which we'll discuss in a second right
here in the Rich Eisen show what is your
feeling about Derek Jeter being a part
owner of the of the Marlins so excited
oh there has been a lot of dysfunction
in that organization there's been a lot
of great moments you know we have two
World Series wins which isn't incredible
for an expansion team but I think
everybody's ready for new blood I think
having a baseball mind at the helm is
really important
I like Mattingly I hope he gets a chance
I'm also worried about what happens to
Stanton like I mean genuinely that is a
player for the ages I can't get ready
they can get rid of him and get a lot
for him and I worry that that's exactly
what they want to do I don't know but I
hope they don't I mean you know we've
gotten
some incredible players over the years
some Hall of Fame players I hope it
doesn't history doesn't repeat it so now
when you say that Josh you're referring
to them as active players or members of
the front office that are being oh poor
Jeff Conine I just read about that I had
no idea until you told me it's so sad
I mean I guess he offered him a smaller
role with less money seems like that
feels like something you say no to I
understand if you came up to me and
you're like Josh I want you to star in
this movie but I don't want to pay you
what you're worth and I also want you to
be an extra in my movie I'd be like rich
I'm not gonna be your movie well I think
I'd try to pitch it a little better than
that but that's it seems like that's the
way they walked in and they're like
guess what we have some great news a man
we don't think you're worth what we've
been giving you and we don't think that
you're worthy of a big yes let's go
pound sand when you say something like
that so let's talk about Murder on the
Orient Express what is it like being in
a fantasy league with Judi Dench oh man
I was she did she let me show you tough
to trade she's tough to trade with she's
a huge Pittsburgh fan he loves the
Steelers she's got her towel she's
always you know it's yeah it's weird was
that annoying on this it was annoying I
was like should he put your Terrible
Towel down you know it's okay like it's
a little too obsessive you know let me
tell you great story the first day she
was in the makeup trailer with me
everybody was intimidated to go up to
her is that right everybody and of
course I'm an idiot including like
Johnny Depp and Willem Dafoe everybody
everybody's like I don't want to bother
her so I go up and I had never met her
before and like and I go up to her and I
go Dame Judi Dench more like damn Judi
day
[Laughter]
we fell in love literally she and I
became like I I called my wife and I was
like I may have to leave you I think
there was an opening here she's just the
most exceptional woman I think I've ever
met she's incredible she has such an
amazing sense of humor she's incredible
was now was there like a five-second
pause where you thought oh my god what
did I just say or was there was that
moment where I'm like oh my god I'm
gonna be blacklisted from film forever
for her to meeting one of the Great's in
the history of acting what a lie no but
I was really proud of it and when it
worked I'm like oh thank gosh yeah thank
God and then were you a fan of the
Agatha Christie a book and the previous
iteration of this absolutely I hadn't
seen the movie and Kenneth Branagh
really who directed and stars in it
really encouraged us not to watch the
movie before we shot when you have a
cast like this but Penelope Cruz Daisy
Ridley Johnny Depp Michelle Pfeiffer
Willem Dafoe I mean the list is crazy
you sort of trust that they're gonna
bring their own process in the table hmm
and that's exactly what happened and I
think he didn't he wanted to make his
definitive version of Murder on the
Orient Express because there have been
great ones yes but he didn't want us to
be in any way feel like we had to copy
anything that had come before hmm
and I don't want it I guess is it true
to the previous iterations order is
there a twist or some juicy rich it's
called buy a ticket to my asking like
when usual suspects comes out so like
Kevin Spacey is he Keyser söze like how
does that whole thing work
no is that a spoiler I feel like it was
and I have no regrets because if your
audience hasn't seen the usual suspects
at this point then they've cheated
themselves understood and is there a
frozen to on them or is it frozen to
more immediately there's an Olaf's
frozen adventure which is coming out in
a couple of minutes with the movie Coco
that you should take your kids to
because it's pretty great done and by
the way just so you could see or
showing on the screen one of our fans of
the Rich Eisen show put Olaf in a
dolphin you're one of your fans
there you go when I found out at Josh
GAD was I admitted I had to draw Olaf as
a fan I love that you've taken my fans
and now you're making them your fans
what was really interesting about that
is he sent that to me the morning of my
team Oh getting crushed 40 to nothing so
I think we should make give Olaf a very
angry melting face instead well but you
know Olaf never understood Miami soap
that summer that summer was a a danger
to me he didn't understand he also
didn't understand that South Florida
sports are a danger to his well-being
the interesting thing is that that Olaf
character in Dolphins uniform sings the
song in Cutler that's what we're all
singing right about now I want to take a
60-second break will you help me you
next segment I want I'm giving away a
subscription to funny or dies app called
pitch yeah - I'll help take it
well the we have a new we have a new
segment on the show a new partnership
with fun of your time okay where we have
writers on their pitch app right the
best I guess idea off of a topic we
throw out and then we have a member of
our of our audience trying best them oh
great yeah topic this week is named the
best first line of a cover letter if
you're applying for the Yankees
managerial job okay very good
next with Josh GAD here in 60 seconds
we'll reveal our pitch Friday and talk a
little bit more about Murder on the
Orient Express with Josh GAD when we
come back here on the Rich Eisen show at
Josh GAD on Twitter to follow him of
which I do and I have for quite some
time I know you are a obviously a fan of
comedy you're in Book of Mormon which
you were brilliant and my wife and I saw
you on we saw you on Broadway doing that
that was terrific I was you know I mean
one of one of my all-time favorite
experiences
being involved with that from day one
and helping create that character with
Trey and Matt who by the way Trey Parker
hmm I told you before huge fan of yours
that's you was so excited that I was
coming on your show today yeah I mean
and I could not be bigger Francis oh I
know Team America is so wrong team
America it's so wrong it's the greatest
it's just the greatest it's it's you
know everything is wrong about that
makes it so funny yeah oh yeah yeah and
Leslie Odom juniors in on the Orient
Express he's you know he's mr. Hamilton
as well and you know my college
classmate I did not know that Leslie and
I were in the same exact class at
Carnegie Mellon studying drama together
damn I know the two of you know now and
now you're on the Orient Express now
together we're on the Orient we're right
now we're in the whodunit so we have a
relationship with one of your died that
we're really proud of we're really
excited about they're gonna should be
thank you very much you've ever done
I've worked with those guys there
they're the best really they're
brilliant they are so funny that will
yeah that Ferrell guy yeah really funny
McKay those guys together so any rate so
they're making some videos for the show
that are coming very very soon okay yeah
there may or may not be something about
the Lavar ball school of homeschooling
that's kind of may or may not be I can't
confirm it okay and then they have a new
app called pitch where writers and folks
in the comedy community go and it's sort
of like an @midnight real-time all right
dozens and dozens of threads for people
to respond to and every single Friday
here on the Rich Eisen show we have our
viewers and listeners try and pitch in
with a response to a topic that we throw
out love it and if we choose them they
get a chance to get a subscription to
the app and we figured out what with you
sitting here we will reveal the top five
answers
I feel very honored I feel very excited
I can very much okay so here we go
here's the the the pitch topic for this
edition of the Rich Eisen show this
Friday was named the best first line to
a cover letter when applying for the
Yankees managers job and an homage to
David Letterman you have the terminal
number five best first sentence to begin
a cover letter when applying for the
Yankees manager job my name is Jeffrey
here and I think you guys still sort of
owe me number four on pitch Friday best
first sentence of being a cover letter
and replying for the Yankees manner job
today I consider myself the most
qualified applicant on the face of the
earth garrick humor which I don't know
is it still to say I feel like it's
still about five years away from that
work number three best sentence to begin
a cover letter I promise not to bet on
baseball this time alright number two
when applying for the Yankees manager
job the best first sentence being a
cover letter it is high it is far it is
with great interest I'm applying to
advantage New York Yankees and then
number one the best first sentence the
beginning cover letter if you hire me is
the next Yankees manager I will build a
big beautiful Sox and Boston will pay
for it there we go Wow that's the winner
and now here's the here's the the winner
that's from the pitch community the
winner of our listener and viewer
contest getting a subscription to pitch
where your jokes get bought so welcome
to the comedy writing community Luis Jay
Rodriguez dear sir/madam
I was referred by George Costanza that's
the first line right there there's a
couple other ones too that we're like I
just knocked over a truck and found 30
Apple watches that was a good one pitch
Friday here on the Richard job guys so
Luis Jay Rodriguez will also get the Hat
that the Commissioner of baseball and
delivered to me at my seat Game two of
the World Series are you going to Game
three no I'm a fort holder this weekend
I have to I got invited and I'm not
going you're not know and I'm really
bummed what's going on I have I have to
open a movie okay that's right at least
that's much better than you know what
I've got to do
okay 7:00 a.m. Eastern 4:00 a.m. Pacific
out here I will be on the set of the NFL
Network getting people excited for the
own seven Brown versus the five and two
Vikings oh boy I wonder how that work
yeah
spoiler alert feels like a safe bet this
week bookie welcome to you know welcome
you know you know I got nothing like I
gotta work on that sir case of Keaney
it's in London it's is it yeah that was
gonna be one of our pitch topics was uh
the British phrase used by Hugh Jackson
to get the Browns their first win I got
a question for you guys what is the
London endgame here like are we gonna
for a team in London or are we just
sending football teams for the question
like how does all that hang on I don't
wash well they know the Jaguars are
playing really well I know I said Blake
bortles is like is two UK fans with
Jerry Lewis was to the great one they
really do Blake bortles is like Joe
Monty mortar on the Orient Express in
theaters near you on November the 10th
check it out at Josh GAD on Twitter come
back anytime I love you brother back at
you for more Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 or DirecTV or
download the
doesn't show up